hey eat a [ __ ] carrot
[Music]
wow guys we could have had a
good production from the beginning but
that's not i
neil brennan am like america in which i
will do the right thing
after i've exhausted every
other option i wanted it simple want to
backdrop did it
so we've got a table now you can't see
it till friday no you'll see a clip
um we've got a table now we've got and
we're working on the lighting we got
this used to be white this backdrop now
it's gray
uh i don't know if you know anything
about photography or video but
white [ __ ] things up made bianca's
frame
troublesome not bianca not is our cam is
racist
it turns out they are hi i'm neil
brennan
so uh you're bianca looks better now
so go back to masturbating to her
instead of just squinting at the frame
okay um bianca you
did not go to a wedding this weekend but
oh by the way we did our love episode
a week and a half ago because this is
i'd like to say
again feeling sorry for myself what a
good boss i am
i we didn't do the show because will
couldn't come
we didn't do it we didn't do it we will
because we'll needed a
needed to go on a break a lot of
producers would go well [ __ ] you
um guess what bro people don't tune in
for you bro
but i'm not gonna lie though if i was
called buddy
a hundred times okay there is
no no buddy there's a kevin hart
commercial coming out where i call him
buddy
and let's see how kind of setting it
sounds okay
um it maybe sounds a little constant
um so it's been a week and a half
it did feel like a vacation and i had to
do a podcast for a week and a half
bianca what did you do well i decided to
go home
i was like you know what the weekend
this is the weekend of my cousin's
wedding in austria
in usda couldn't go so instead of my own
visit my mom
and my family i actually had to do
something up there and i was like oh
this is a perfect amount of time
i have nothing to do go up there
straight into a fiery inferno
and i was like i just laughed yeah jeff
i just laughed about it when i was like
man
so i escaped one you know potential
dangerous situation there's no this is
the
this is climate change earth i
woke up when i was driving there that's
when i
i mean i knew the fires were up there
but i just didn't i knew
that was gonna happen but i didn't
realize how close they were
to the route i had to take to get to san
jose so i'm from 408 for the south bay
thank you there were so many fires i
didn't realize how
far spread out i knew about but there's
so many that you literally are like oh
this is
the newest fire you know it's not like
are there like
different smoke supplies or something
like how do you know
driving from here to san jose when is it
when does it start getting bad it got
bad um like
so when you go to san jose you have to
cut through the state to get
westward by a highway called the 152. so
that goes through gilroy
so as you're going from the five you
have to get westward and go up
this is in your big rig got to go up
gilroy you get on 152.
so on the 152 i just saw
actual smoke and i'm like and it was
orange and it was 2pm and everything was
orange and then i just pulled over well
when i went to rest stop i looked at the
fire map
and it was amazing i pulled over i
needed it i needed a whiz
all my whiz bags were full and no
everything was
by the time i got there in the afternoon
it was dark
and orange in curb potato
cappuccino cupertino yeah yeah it was
weird it was very scary and the next
morning
like the shades were kind of open and
when the sun like rose it my entire room
was orange
orange the color orange from outside i
know
but it was just weird to like
wake up with a filter on yeah everything
looked like sepia it was like
i mean i like was it amazing i have so
many people to the next level uh i just
was like
living in an old-timey photo yeah
it was weird it was very strange and it
made me really
sad
you know i'm a cassandra from way back
but this is the new
world what a cassandra is a is an is a
it's a debbie downer from the 1800s
i actually think it's from greek
mythology you know
[Music]
great um so
yeah this is the new world and the same
way
that uh america all these countries
you're not allowed to co
you can't go anywhere yeah so what's
gonna happen with climate change
but it's just going to be like sri lanka
you're flooding
sorry there's you cannot come into our
country
because we're at capacity
[Music]
and there's going to be well in that
case i'm happy to be in america
plenty of space uh space but
rising tide i mean we're talking about
50 years from now but
they're gonna canada's gonna build a
wall
they should yeah we're weird
that's a nice way of putting it
america's a weirdo
shut up mara's wah uh i was listening to
this report when i was up there about
the wildfires
and it was saying that there's so many
factors like one
the fact that they didn't handle covid
enough
in the prisons made them there's so
many there's so less um prison
firefighters available
uh another thing that i thought was
really interesting
for example oregon like we have a fire
season which is so strange
marin does the funniest bit on it yeah
he i thought about the bit a lot
i did too i was like there's fires and
ants
anyways um so
oregon was not prepared like we have a
lot of
equipment a lot going on there
at the helicopter that can hold the most
amount of water like their biggest
helicopter
is deployed in afghanistan so they just
didn't have
whoops that was a type that was a close
one
who said why or what
so organs [ __ ] and the most
interesting thing i learned is that
the reason why so there's so little
affordable housing
that uh development's going
out farther and farther outside of the
cities like urban areas
so to get all this they have to somehow
be insurable but they're saying that
they're going to have
they're coming to a head with their
problems there's so many fires now like
if it's
going to be this bad and this is the new
thing with climate change
that now insurance companies might not
insure those properties and then they're
just
rendered useless so no one's going to
like it's this
really weird everything's unfortunately
connected and that's when
changes happen is when insurance goes
well we're not [ __ ] covering that
isn't that so funny that the whole
[ __ ] countries ran on insurance
yeah i mean it's not surprising it's not
surprising it's just
it's just you can't do in a in a in a
uh litigious society right it's like
okay what do you want to do
what could go wrong you get sued for
can't do it we're not covering you you
can't do it
right uh homo plenty of homeowners
plenty of it's also like raising tons of
uh uh it's just all bad
it's just all bad it's it's all bad and
we gots to change you understand
how climate change man right but we got
to change
even we have to change to deal with
climate change i mean like we have to
adjust because there
apparently pollution's going to be down
like eight percent this year which is
like
that's not enough you guys sorry
that's not for a for the world is shut
down and like
guess what we we changed it eight
percent
it's like i was thinking more like 60.
but you know what there's these like
in these pro um climate change
infographics that you see and they're
always like
if we all didn't drive for
one day we could save a million fish
and i don't see the benefit of i don't
see as much i i see the benefit of like
us sheltering in place during the
pandemic at the time
but how quick does it go back to [ __ ] a
day
it doesn't it doesn't i did a joke all
those nature is healing
nature's healing i saw a dolphin
but it's the most wishful thinking of
all time it's 200 years of us polluting
right every [ __ ] day garbage
uh air pollution sludge chemicals
yeah we take off for a month
a dolphin shows up and we're like well
that was close huh
we problem solved it's i said it's like
the
your fat roommate who has a carrot on
new year's day and says well that should
take care of my diabetes
i had to go out for fat people you know
wow what i do
um they're gonna get it there's a lot of
uh
letters about obesity this week as well
which is pretty exciting
if you're just tuning in um
anyhow so that's it's
it's a we're it's we're in a sticky
situation
uh the world now speaking of sticky
situations gang
you know michael cohen
and bob woodward bob woodward both
wrote uh books about president trump
uh here's what i like about michael
cohen
the the fact that journalists
and talk show host seth adamant
uh have to talk to this guy
like he's legitimate because here's the
thing people don't realize about michael
cohen
he would still be the president's lawyer
if he could be
i believe that right now he would go
back to
to switching places between his life now
and his life from three years ago
he it it was his identity yeah uh and
the only reason he stopped
is because he got raided right that's
the only he didn't stop
by his own volition he stopped because
the government said you have to stop and
now he's like
you know that was wrong for what i was
doing
first of all i'd also like to that
michael cohen is like if
a billy joel song in a men's warehouse
had a baby on the side of the long
island expressway
um it's that's who he is he's such a
[ __ ] long island
mook there's no other word he's a mook
guys a mook
please i mean i know you have to have
them on but but
he should apologize twice
in every sentence he say like hey
america i'm sorry about what i
did to help the president it's good to
be here rachel hey america
sorry about what i did to help the
president every [ __ ] sentence he
should repeat himself
because he's so loathsome yeah
and his behavior was so
criminal and aided
a cartel in taking over the government
yeah and doesn't seem all these people
are only
sorry they got caught not remorseful he
didn't check into rehab on his own
he checked into rehab because he got
[ __ ] caught that's not
he also is only writing this book to
[ __ ] make money
yes i that i don't mind i get that
no that's fine i just mean like his
hands his uh you know
original means of making money are tired
and they i think they tried to freeze
his assets at some point
so i think he's just like he's a scrappy
long island dude
he's like i
so sounds so bad i don't know i know it
sounds bad but it's like
what it's like from uh it sounds racist
it sounds racist and like anti-italian i
believe
it's that racism someone in mean streets
first time i heard it somebody called
somebody a mook in main streets and he
goes mook what's a mook
you can't call me a mook a stupid or
incompetent person that guy's a [ __ ]
mook
mook um so
it's fanuc where's it no that sounds
racist hey hey hey
now you're being racist um
so [ __ ] em again
you gotta talk to him but ab
don't forget he still wants to be doing
what he did yeah
he would still he would in a second if
trump called him today he would do it
i heard that trump the reason why they
like do business with each other is
because he's so
he's like he's like a moral yeah he's
just like a
kook uh lawyer and trump ran through so
many lawyers and he was the one that
would like do the
[ __ ] he finished like 300 out of 325 in
his class
and uh and
was and it was a shitty law school um
and uh i don't even remember um
is there a shitty law schools i mean i
think look it up but
don't worry about it um don't worry
about it well um
you should check your emails um uh
wait is there are there shitty law
schools yeah that's interesting
everything yeah i guess trump's lawyer
went to the worst law school in america
that's the headline thomas m cooley law
school
at western michigan wow that's the worst
it sounds weird it sounds worse than it
coolly law
yeah he's he's amoral and he was
like a taxi cab lawyer he was a lawyer
for immigrants to get medallion i mean
this is a [ __ ]
it's a mook he's like i got a guy
yes he's i got a guy give me 20 minutes
i'll take care of it right he also
pronounced the word uh aggrandizement
as awfully as i've ever heard it
said aggrandizing
self-aggrandizing i texted melania and i
go
i found a lot of the oh hello
pronunciations a little broad until i
heard michael cohen say aggrandizing
right
aggrandizing [ __ ]
piece of garbage um so
i but i believe every word he said i
actually believe no i like that
i'm not saying he's a liar i'm just
saying please he should just
there should be some price to pay
uh for what a piece of garbage it was
yeah that's the only time i s not
sympathize with trump i'm like
dude this guy's a scumbag like he is a
scumbag he's just
saying co-owner trump no trump's a
stomach i mean
he's just like dude he did the dirt now
he wants to write a book and act like oh
my god this guy is so
terrible right this thing i told him we
should do
it's the it goes from we to he i'm sure
at a certain point yeah
for sure in the there's some [ __ ]
milk
[Music]
thank you what um what do you know no
but in
michael cohen's book do you know some of
the allegations i didn't
what's in his book that's not in other
books that's what i'm saying he actually
says like there's
kind of not he had nothing to do with
anything russian
yeah i believe that it's a lot of the
stormy daniel stuff and a lot of
karen mcdougall and yeah
um karen mcdougall was the
disappointment that she fell for it
because she's cute she's cute
yeah like really and also the
the fake obama that trump hired that is
so
it's so crazy that's so interesting yes
the fake obama that he hired to
it's and they didn't fake obama quit
oh i bet i don't know i think i read
that yeah but that's
i mean quit what that's like when people
go to
you know places where there's weird like
homeless people like
let me beat you up for a hundred bucks
no it's weirder than that
what president oh it's the president of
the united states
and a billionaire hiring or whatever
a rich person hiring a look-alike
to yell at him it's like a partial like
[ __ ] and like immersion therapy
or something it's so like i'm so jealous
of whoever gets to learn this part of us
history
like i mean they're not gonna believe i
mean there's gonna have to be somebody
like
i swear this happened i swear this
happened they're going to be like all
right tomorrow
kids bring in everyone find a tweet that
president
tweeted and we'll talk about that and
then everyone's gonna be like i
like it yes
and people were finally then they said
it was kitten yes it's a
it is a it's so thankfully there's a
couple podcasts
that you these kids can listen to in the
future hello
yeah children yellow uh woodward wrote a
book also
that that one those snippets were
interesting the recordings
yeah um were
the so trump knew about
the co how bad coveted was in january
february 8th is when that recording's
from
and uh but the interesting thing about
the recording
he sounded intelligent oh my god that's
what i
thought i was like i believe this you
actually sound coherent
you don't you sound like an intelligent
person
yeah like you don't he didn't sound like
a moog for once no
he didn't sound he sounded so
i believed him i felt like they were
really having like a regular
conversation he wasn't hiding anything
he was being really truthful
if he would have literally just done
that just that
what i don't understand what's yes uh
because
you if you listen to trump's
speech pattern it sounds like he's
talking to a child
publicly publicly like one day like a
miracle it will disappear
and you won't like that but most of what
he says
is like that just like sing songy like a
child
like you talk to a child like a child
but you realize that
he's 73 and had money his whole life and
um and
other businessmen would be like the [ __ ]
you talking to me like this yeah
um so yeah you guys sounds competent
you you wouldn't be terrified to work
with him
yeah you wouldn't be terrified no that
was the shock
but the fact that he knew and
downplayed it is just so insane i don't
know if they're gonna do it
i pitched a sketch to roy wood for the
daily show
um called trump home security where when
there's a break-in
they will not alert you because they
don't want you to panic
and eventually the the like america the
burglar would just disappear
um but yeah it's the the the
uh what i came away with is and i made
an instagram video about this is like i
just can't i'm flooded
i cannot the same way i can't my brain
can't fire serotonin
it can't even because of trump it can't
fire cortisol
anymore i can't get mad i literally
i try to get mad
he what nothing happens
yeah nothing happens and i feel like
i mean people were sad seconding it
by that i mean liking it i'm from the
from the 1800s
many seconds i get many secondings
cassandra um i'm being a real cassandra
over here
uh but
i hope he loses you know on my
little my little road trip little
posters i like when people
come back from places and go you know
they have a lot of trump lawn things
uh no not in the bay area um but
uh outside the bay area right outside
it's not gilroy either because there's a
lot of mexican people even though
they're like more agriculture mexicans
are more for him
than you think no but these there's a
lot of like farm
agriculture workers like that were in
the field so i feel like they're just
kind of like
just leave us the [ __ ] alone yeah uh but
i did stop a few times and
i kept calling it like broke man sturgis
there was a
giant bikers meeting like randomly in
the middle of
lebeck some [ __ ] town
no mask i mean the trump flags were so
it was
at that point i'm like i don't know
if it's this guy's good for the country
and i believe in him uh
if as much as it is like
this is the [ __ ] is the horse we've
been it's i said i like this guy
and i don't want to seem it's the it's
what do people
who do people think they are and they
want to be like i'm a man of my word
when i
say i'm for somebody i ain't no fair
weather supporter
yeah and i'm not gonna let some liberal
yeah tell me
what's right and wrong when you're out
here killing babies
um by the way we're not many of us
aren't killing that many babies
um but that's what it is it's they don't
want to seem
soft or that they learned anything
they'd rather bet on the wrong horse
then
agree with you then agree with him
then a fruity ass liberal no it's just
not gonna happen
there's a person i know when i was in
the bay keep it anonymous
and this person is a white male
that doesn't pay their taxes in smoke
sweet okay
a hardcore trump supporter mm-hmm it
never makes sense yeah it doesn't make
sense they just hate liberals
yeah i was talking to my buddy devin who
writes for the daily show and we were
his in-laws are trump people and
um he was saying that and he was in
jersey he was at the jersey shore and
he's like
a lot of trump flags on these boats
which i want to say to people
can trump run for president of the sea
sir would you mind running for president
of the seas
um they
republicans love money more
than liberals love justice
yeah that's the bottom line most people
who
identify as a republican don't have
money most people they have a lot of
money
there's a lot of money in logic to a
feelings fight
it's the old uh they're poor and they
use social services yeah i don't
understand
that everybody this is attributed to
nine different people i think alex
alexis de tocqueville said it but
america is uh a nation of
temporarily embarrassed rich people so
nobody's
actually it's like i'm now i'm poor
right but i'm taking a class i got this
app
you know if you do if you fill out
surveys at home
yeah 300 bucks a day so
question yeah do you think a lot more
people
are trump supporters on the outside
because i feel like you know when you're
kind of losing some people
cheer the loudest like come on [ __ ] no
[ __ ] him even though
you know whatever it's like oh whatever
[ __ ] uh will the people do you think
will people get in the booth and vote
for biden
i mean like do you think so we're seeing
trump
people more preachy than we are biden
people mm-hmm
is that out of just like
trying to be defiant like [ __ ] you so i
don't know if the flags represent
the amount of people you know what i
mean it's just i'm you're seeing it more
i think it's he he's more
he's he evokes more passion but i think
people who are voting for biting
biden aren't as of course not but
there's i feel like there's more
they're just not i don't i don't trust
myself
anymore i don't trust pollsters i don't
trust me no pollsters i don't i also
think that
people don't vote people
who want them the first time it was kind
of fun
and loose and a little hateful
like yeah he's a little hateful that's
just my guy
now it's like no this [ __ ] is
hateful and it's a little fun like the
the proportions
have changed flipped so i think
you can make an argument that there's
more secret people this time
because you're more secret trump because
there
now it's there is a social price to pay
there's no
the you can't say it's fun it's like no
i'm for hate
which by the way uh 63 of white people
are voting for him
so on the on the record that's on the
record that you're
telling a pollster yes i'm hateful
right so when people go notice i'm like
they're more apt to lie this time than
they were last time
so i actually believe it less this time
i feel like there's a lot of
people in trump's circles that cannot
admit they're not into it
i just so polarizing if you're rich
there's
no if to devin's point if you like money
more than justice
that he's the only game in town look
democratic if you vote democratic and
you're rich
i have so much you know neil
a lot of praise you usually have a lot
of people guys i don't have to be here
i don't have to be liberal i mean i do
it for you
imagine like if he for me if it was like
vote for this piece of [ __ ] but you
would
pay so much less in taxes yeah i don't i
get it would be a struggle
greed and racism is a wonderful american
political platform
and that's what his platform is yeah
it's a reliable
decent platform yeah tried and true
yes so you know
i don't i don't trust any pulse yeah i
just don't trust them uh because i
bet i offered to bet somebody a hundred
thousand dollars i shouldn't have said
that out loud
on election day last time that
hillary would win and that person
did they ask you for the money he didn't
take the bet
he was hosting standing alive that week
oh cr is it a krapel
i don't know i never i didn't catch his
name okay
um andrew gillum this is a heartbreaking
story i don't know who the [ __ ] this is
uh we had an hour you could have looked
it up andrew gillum
is uh you'll recognize him he's the
he is the act he ran for governor of
florida
almost won and then got caught
in a miami hotel room on having a
a wild gay weekend or or as gay people
call it
just a weekend because everything they
do
in my experience sexually and
parting-wise
is next level yeah they're not
um so
he got caught probably six months ago
and today he came out as he identifies
as bisexual
okay andrew yeah what's the problem
uh the problem well the problem is she
ain't winning florida again
no i mean look we're shallow in our
politics
yeah you have to be perfect pristine
do the thing that we want you to do so i
feel comfortable even though
i don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
yeah your sexuality is never gonna
no no you're not gonna make gay laws
you're not gonna make gay traffic laws
like you know what this
is this is gay traffic laws
um we need a purple light yeah um but
so uh
so i that's just it's interesting this
speaks to what we said before
should they should more people come out
he will not benefit
from this it depends on what you're
doing i think
then again you're right remember we were
talking about men
it never benefits a man to come out
yeah and a woman i feel like there's
something in guys
that are like i can still [ __ ] her i
mean
because if she's really a lesbian you
know yeah man she ain't met me yet
man she gay now she see me with my shirt
off
uh i'm on one i'm over on route 153
152 i'll come through uh gilroy
uh yeah it's it never benefits
men to come out bootage i don't think it
helped him
uh really i don't think it hurt him i
think it
he was such a [ __ ] weasely villain
but
yes but that really hurt him but the
me bigger issue what i mean at weasley
villain he's [ __ ] liberal and he was
in the military
yeah but that's not the point we're not
talking about what you are on paper
right we're talking about
what really affects you but i don't
again
i i think buddha judge is mediocre but i
don't think he's a
weaselly vil i mean villain is like a
vocal
thing i just mean aesthetically he was
kind of
what are we talking about here we're
talking about politicians yeah
what do you what is it i don't think
he's a weasley
he comes across a weasley villain i
don't think politically he's a weasley
no but we're not talking about
the reality we're talking about the
shallow politics of
like the identity politics who are you
what do you seem how do you seem like
they're the same thing that kamala
brought a [ __ ] hot sauce around to
prove that she was black it's the same
[ __ ]
i'm politically a weasel but he just
came across
like right but why doesn't aoc why don't
you describe her as a vain
you know what i mean about her though
she did a makeup tutorial
that's not the crux of who she is but
again your slice of buddha just
is tiny and i'm just while it's okay
like
[ __ ] him he's a weasley whatever right
she's okay no no you're like comparing
apple's oranges i'm just saying in the
debates
in the primaries he didn't come across
well he came across a really
kind of weasley needling he came across
as a corporate show
so andrew gillum
there was a guy named harold ford in the
2000s who was a uh
who was a politician in tennessee and he
did all the talk shows and he
was he was like fine is he black he's
mixed
but these guys are just like duds he's a
dud he was a member of the
he's a member of the there's not most
people in politics aren't stars
right so andrew gillum's like i'm trying
to make this thing and it's like
you've never won a [ __ ] election or
he was the mayor of tallahassee i think
but okay but
uh these guys are just not
their eighth leads in a movie
they're the eighth league they're not
the lead right leads only you know who i
didn't know you know that john david
washington guy
who's in tennant yeah denzel's son
oh yeah yeah no idea
oh no idea i just thought he was a guy
no yeah yeah he looks
exactly like his mom it's like oh
tough one no no but i'm saying if you
want to be a movie star
you're better off looking like one of
the biggest movies ever i had no idea
that
that he was denzel's son that's fine and
i've said this before
and i'll say it again
i like it when a little black nebula
doesn't breaks out love a black nebula i
love it
i'll love it for about a hundred years
then i'll start resenting it he
he has the funniest denzel impression
obviously but
oh that's great i love when sons like um
jd witherspoon when he does johnny's
impression it's so
that's funny it's great i'm like thank
god this transferred um
that's great i had no idea that's funny
um i
tenant yes didn't knit i'll see it
eighth
lead politicians okay politicians eighth
lead john david washington okay got it
um and yeah andrew gillums and a slate
seventh lead fires we covered we don't
like them we don't
uh uh you know about this white
professor jessica krug
yes if you don't know who she is
she doesn't live
yes she's uh she's
krugazol jessica krisal she
pretended to be different
types of black she she was north
american
black oh uh american black
and caribbean so wait what do you mean
north american black and she
said like she i think she i don't she
said
different type like she just represented
herself in different ways
here's the funny thing she actually
makes
rachel dolezal look like sojourner truth
because rachel's old didn't benefit at
all no
she [ __ ] got publishing the funny
thing is she
as a black book yes she wrote a book and
it was on
like the it made the harriet tubman list
for like best wow writing about
oppression and slavery it made alyssa
like
she got deal she got ten year professor
uh it's pretty great she really did the
damn thing
she was like look at that now look at it
like where he wants to be
what the f also she looks latina i mean
that's fine you can be
you can look all sorts and be black but
what did she i'd prefer you be clearly
black though
just for my own receipts so that i know
what
how racist i can be around you um yo
how did it get out that i don't know i
think she turned herself in
she did she turned herself in she self
canceled she went to the she went to the
yeah
guys and i'm jessica krug and
i've been living a lie um
wow what makes someone just say
you know i keep getting asked if i'm
black i'm just gonna go for it
like what it's soul man it's that movie
soul man oh my god
see thomas howard like it's soul man
soul woman
which i think they made kind of a
version of soul man saw a woman
um she said
to an escalating degree over my adult
life i've astute astute's a tough one to
pronounce you never know
my lived experience as a white jewish
child in suburban kansas city
under various assumed identities with a
blackness that i had no right to claim
first north american blackness which is
what drake is
um then u.s rooted blackness then
caribbean rooted bronx blackness
she coming from my people all my people
she's a
old caribbean she's old caribbean girl
um i'm not a culture vulture i'm a
culture leech
this [ __ ] went and told on herself oh
good job like a black
woman she's a little black
and hot women are not dressing herself
but i'm saying they'll
they'll tell on somebody else she turned
it on herself she's like
she did that [ __ ] there's a problem in
here
um she's doing averses against herself
wow
yeah well the nice thing is she's
basically a comedian
she's like i'm gonna tell on myself
where you could ever tell me comedians
always make fun of me she ethered
herself she did the uh she is white she
has a [ __ ] bum she does live in a
trailer with a mom
yeah she wrote a boy is an uncle tom
who shot him named cheddar bob it's
eminem
um uh is her husband black
i don't know if she's married okay so uh
that sounds like a [ __ ] solo lie
to me yeah also
man um
what a what an annoying
thing to have to keep up yeah i don't
she
here's okay here's something i've been
thinking about yeah
so as much as i say dole is all
got nothing i think we
have to start
acknowledging that attention and
sympathy
are currency sympathy
in our intention yeah for sure in our
country like as much as you go
what did so and so get from the
attention don't act like it's nothing
the whole [ __ ]
phone is based on attention and you get
it
and and and serotonin fires and
and dopamine and all that [ __ ] so
we have to uh
acknowledge that as so dole's all got
attention and sympathy
that she never would have gotten as a as
a white woman yeah
um now she did have two adopted black
sons so she would have gotten
dolezal dead she would have gotten
they were adopted i thought she had them
no they were adopted okay
did you see that i went in such a deep
dive in dolezal
i found all these songs that her husband
made for her
they're on youtube it's like rachel wait
rachel her
black dude yes of course they're so
funny i love them i played them so many
times um
but yeah and she was really like living
it i feel like
rachel was it's more
yeah i get what you mean though i know
attention and all that stuff
it's a it's not a tenure or a book deal
but it's you know rachel dolezal
as the head of the seattle as the
spokane and double ac players
the white islands um
it was her and two dominicans was the
whole thing
that all was the meeting um because they
couldn't find anybody
okay you get it i'm not gonna explain my
comedy video unless you name me too
um the kind of attention dollars all got
nine grand a year it's the current
value of street value right nine grand
this lady was getting money
millions well not millions but you don't
think
no not for not not if your book makes
the harry tubman list
it's probably not flying off the shelf
what what's that supposed to mean
it means it's any list helps
had you heard of the harry tubman list
i've heard of the harry tubman list i've
heard of all these like
i've never heard of the hard time unless
um the
the like the new york times how the the
booker pro
like they're the there are there's a
list but harry comes out
and before uh
uh ta-nehisi coates there was
this wasn't a big market like for like
[ __ ] broadside
books about racism wasn't a big margin i
know how it is
i actually want to know what was her
book about that made it
uh read that fugitive modernities
uh kisama and the politics of freedom
um that's not the name of the book but
that's like it was about
it's called fugitive modernities
which that someone should have brought
maybe mention that
no black person would name a book that
before it was like you know what i mean
ew fugitive no come on no
self-respecting black person named
modernity kasama and the politics of
freedom can you imagine if you brought
that to a book club it's a book
no no we're not doing that
uh who else who else got a book idea um
yeah we're not doing that did you do
maternity so funny
yeah so so yeah i
but she apparently knew her [ __ ] oh yeah
you can be a
white professor of african-american
studies yes
but just don't pretend you're black
yeah that's all we ask just don't
pretend you're blind please
don't do it please ma'am uh so
jessica krug rest in peace
queen rest in peace um
nfl started that was so weird
i only watched i watched the game
in kansas city whatever where they booed
did you see that one
yeah my whole family loves the ball it
was so gross
they hate black people
yeah tolerate it's the tolerance they
but they
only like it's like play family like
them
during this interval yeah it's
you want to talk about conditional love
and so
yeah conditions i guess if you're a
player
do you i'm sure they knew well these
white [ __ ] don't really give a
[ __ ] about us right just
generally especially in the interactions
of like very rarely
do they
just [ __ ] boo a thing about
unity i mean they were doing unity
they're bringing unity
in like a pandemic when there wasn't
that many of them and they barely got
and that's what you choose to focus on
is
boo to this thing yes these guys are
like
risking their i mean whatever that kind
of risk in their lives but
but um yeah like what do you
wonder if it makes them not second guess
or question what they're doing because i
i think they all understand that it's
dangerous but i feel like that's a level
of
venom or uh
you can't it's hard to
once you see it you can't unsee it yeah
you can trick yourself into going like
ah it's a couple
it's a couple bad apples the funny thing
is people are saying don't
uh politicize the game yeah but
the government spends millions of
dollars i think
flyovers and all that yeah and the
pentagon gives the nfl
millions and millions of tens of
millions of dollars to have like
military
displays yeah so looks like we're
we're politicizing something it's like
we're using it as
stop politicizing you first you first
also
look at all the other justin let's just
take trump look at all the things that
he has politicized that doesn't need to
be politicized
a pandemic for example yeah every other
so we don't even know more examples
pandemic and boats that's it
and so it's like you why so every you
can
politicize everything and the moment
these people you it just it's
it's so raging hypocrites raging
there's to quote president trump there's
a
there's a hypocrite out there and it's
raging you ever see that footage of him
talking about the helicopters
no oh it's the best the daily show
what's that speak up you need to speak
up what's that daily show did a montage
of [ __ ] hilarious but it's just funny
like okay when the blm was happening
when it was making news at least
everything was like take these signs
down
get these signs or take them down and
yeah these signs are
gigan all the trump flags i saw were
gigantic everyone is screaming so
i just like don't what were you saying
you're promising if the white players
did something to commemorate the the
confederacy they would [ __ ]
this is bonkers they need to hire extra
security because we will be running on
the field to
suck their dicks from the back you know
i will say
suck my dick from the back
uh i will say and i hate to admit it but
i was around a lot of
flags on the road that [ __ ] blue
lives matter flag is a nice looking flag
and i'm annoyed it's not the black lives
matter flag
because it's not colorful and it just
has like one
thing of color it's the it's the image
it's a black and white with one blue
which is i'm no [ __ ] that but
aesthetically
i mean kevin christie made the
observation find a badder flag than
the then the isis flag and i'll give you
a lot of money that's
one of the great flags it's that it's a
nazi flag
i mean you want to talk about
graphically
the swastika was just a graphic element
before
right before they made it about all
their stuff
all their garbage all that baggage they
had am i right
boy oh boy give it a rest hitties yeah
that's hitler heck homemade
um yeah so yeah there's a lot of nice
flags out there
it was annoying to me because i'm like
[ __ ] shout out like in
every time i saw a cop blue lives matter
i mean whatever there's this
debate but it just it's funny that
the hypocrisy that you have to believe
in yourself that
no stop don't do that put your flag away
that's disrespectful shut up and dribble
play the game but then i'm gonna do
whatever the
[ __ ] i want completely selective people
are just staying in the locker rooms
for the all the all the songs
which is to me it's
worse than kneeling but suit yourself
just don't play
if you're against it if you're like it
just seems like
the kneeling was to protest police
violence
singing in the locker room is like i
don't know
i don't know what i like it seems more
severe
like i won't even be around that [ __ ] i
don't even i don't [ __ ] with that song
like that and but by the way it's white
players also like
oh yeah it's a team decision i do like
that there's more
it's more of a conversation you know
than before
it was weird this would never happen if
black
george floyd and coven can you imagine
them
even bringing this much
and they play the black the black
national anthem i love it
i couldn't sing it i couldn't no i don't
know one word i don't love the song i
love that they're playing it
um will you even though you don't know
even though they could be playing it
right now and you wouldn't know because
you wouldn't know unless they told you
neither would you
[Music]
all right dak prescott who is a cowboy
not literally plays for the football
team called the cowboys
said that he went to a therapist and
because his brother committed suicide
and he was isolated from covid
and he was like i need to speak to a
therapist and then skip
bayless uh who
i gotta say i rare who skip bayless who
i meant to retweet people like him no
skip bayless is
the nancy grace of sports really
he's just like he's just oh
he's southern so he said that
uh dak prescott was weak it's just the
and the other thing is they're very
rarely do i think these guys
try to court controversy i know
skip bayless is from alcoholism i feel
like he's gone to 12-step meetings i
feel like he does
shovel looking he's got that disheveled
look that we have when you go up around
alcoholism yep
um you see it looking good he's also
kind of
like way older than you think he is
really how does he
he's uh he's gonna be he's 69.
um 68. um damn he look doesn't look that
bad
are you not that one yeah there's a
couple where he doesn't
uh so i think that he is in went out of
his way to just be controversial
is dak prescott is he white
uh don't know what he looks like no he's
a
he's he's a proud blackman
um no but it's just dumb it's the
[ __ ] dumbest
it's just so dumb but so in the world of
sports
like you know there's the one yelling
guy he's a stephen a smith and him used
to have a show together
right i think and are they both seen as
similar yeah i think yeah
people like stephen a smith more because
he's
funnier and more charismatic okay
uh and and skip is just
uh like a crank
but he probably he appeals more to like
racists
is he more conservative in his view does
he yes what is his view of
i do about blm i don't know and just the
anthem and stuff i don't know how much i
don't
know okay um because again these guys
are morons they just say [ __ ]
to get shared they're not i shouldn't
say they're morons they're
certainly not mooks they're on their
skip bayless has got one foot in mooc
territory
uh stephen a is more doing it for the
circus and
being funny uh bayless to me
is not is is the kind of guy who
never laughs just always intense like
you know you've never seen trump laugh
think i've seen him laugh
what did he laugh at oh not laugh laugh
that's [ __ ] crazy that's weird that
you've never seen trump laugh
that's crazy you really truly haven't
like someone did this and i was like
oh yeah like hahahaha thinking back to
all the people
you've never heard him not break no
he doesn't really break form not never
ran away never
slapped it never it's like a
turn it's like a type of sociopathy he
skip bayless is from alcoholism so
i'm i tend to give him a little more but
not much
do you think though he just was
trying to say something
i think he was intentionally doing
[ __ ]
right i think he was intentionally doing
it to be to just get
because the argument's so weird eight
thousand dollars worth of attention
honestly
that's it i argue straight up it's just
a dumb argument
it's all don't show weakness regressive
and and
and runs counter to everything that
culture is
headed toward but it does fall in line
with the booing where it's like
i don't give a [ __ ] what's going on with
you well it
yes it's not about it's not about his
race i think
i think it's about men don't go to
therapy which is dumb
yeah and in football just play don't i
don't want to hear about your sadness i
don't
you couldn't work out oh yeah just
[ __ ] play the game you're the leader
of the team like that's
it's so i don't know it's so strange
that we're so hard on you
when it comes to sports are dumb in
their feelings uh to quote your
boyfriend blake griffin
basketball is a game invented for
children
now basketball i don't even saw this
steve nash
do you remember steve now game and vp
like nash yes
two-time mvp steve nash that's the thing
people forget about him
he's married to a black lady i think no
not true oh um she is quite white i'll
have you now quite
uh steve nash became
the um became
the coach of the new jersey nets now
layla frederick that's not a black girl
um that's his wife
uh became the coach of the new jersey
nets
and people were saying stephen a smith
the other guy
the other mouthy yeah uh was saying that
it was white privilege
that he got the job because he's never
coached an nba team
uh then but aren't some aren't a lot of
coaches former players
yes and charles barkley pointed out that
there have been guys who got jobs
without
prior experience players but not a lot
no but some and
but stephen a smith's counter argument
was they didn't get
jobs on teams that good
it they got like college now just shitty
or
shitty or nba jobs in some way steve
kerr steve kerr was never
he was a he was a gm
before he was coach i and steve kirk
i'm sorry uh steve nash kind of admitted
to
a bit of white privilege yeah uh
but in some cases it's like i don't know
man
yeah people get jobs for [ __ ]
it's not all like get them
get the fairness get the level out but
it's
perfect then what's up with i feel like
you have
you feel some sort of way about steven
uh something saying that or no no
i don't i don't think he's exactly wrong
okay uh barkley actually was more hated
he was like he shouldn't say [ __ ] like
this because when you talk about race
it's too important but barkley seems to
not he seems like he doesn't
budge easy in agreeing with things it
races motivated reasoning
which are the voters have um the trump
voters no he doesn't but but i
but when it comes to race he actually
said we never talked about on the
podcast but a player
black player called a white player [ __ ]
ass white boy
and in the bubble you can really yeah
you can
you can it's a it's a super bowl of lip
reading it's [ __ ] amazing
and uh and barkley
jacks shaq and kenny were saying like
yeah dudes say [ __ ] like that all the
time and barclay goes
i've never used race in an insult
but then that's just from your [ __ ]
experience
no no but he's saying he to i'm trying
to
answer your thing about him sort of
being okay he
fine and like if i believe him if he
says i've never used
raise an insult i believe him uh
with the white privilege thing and
saying stephen a smith
uh shouldn't play around with that [ __ ]
i mean i think that's the
i think it's the world now like i don't
but
i don't think net would nash have gotten
the job
would a black two-time mvp have you
gotten a
coaching job on a good team
who are there black and two-time mvps
mostly
they're mostly black and two-time well
you know the coaches versus the players
i mean it's a real
it's a jump but also not it is and it
isn't i mean most of the coaches are
white
yes as a champion and most of the
players are black
i mean you got to keep them in line even
the great players most of them are black
so
there is obviously this you know
right so what i'm saying is because
there's not a one-to-one
would michael jordan have gotten a job
without
work paying his dues yes
could lebron yes go so
you think he's on the level of lebron
and michael jordan
steve nash i'm trying to find someone no
i know hey will you look up mvp
and nba mvp by year it'll be on
wikipedia interesting
yeah it'll be it's there's a couple deep
dive let's do it
there's a couple um
you know all right so this is from the
beginning
all right so moses malone two time larry
bird three time
oh larry bird became a coach
quickly but white i believe he was a gm
magic magic i believe coached the lakers
at one point
barkley ain't taking that kind of pay
cut hakeem
is too serious and anti he's just too
serious
david robinson i feel like could get a
job
duncan tim duncan tim duncan good at
coaching job
i believe he could get a head coaching
job without go back for a second
um yeah you think tim duncan can
i believe he can because he's got uh
oh derek rose is hot as hell oh
interesting
i wouldn't guess that for you he's so
hot i just there's some people are just
he's got an asiatic look
there i said it it's got an asiana club
so funny um
is has uh has curry he's still playing
so curry could get a job do you think
afterwards he could probably yeah
uh curry could get a job because they
can go well his dad was a player he's a
player
he's got good lenny they they can make a
reason they can
come with a reason he could have kobe
could have i believe
kobe would have gotten a job uh lebron
could have durant i don't think durant
could
i don't they or james harden hardin
couldn't either because
they're not
very compelling people honestly patrick
ewing couldn't get it patrick ewington
assistant he's a
yeah he works he's been in us but he's
never he's gets past overhead coaching
jobs
oh wow i don't because
he's not that compelling a guy
now having said that are all coaches
compelling no
are do you need to be compelling to go
from player to coach without
uh paying dues i would argue yes you do
yes will you go back to that list uh
will
yeah lebron do you think he's compelling
enough to yeah and he's
also verbose like you have to be you
have to be like a character
evocative and and talkative you know
what's funny too you
said this thing before we were talking
about in the primaries and stuff how
some people just look presidential and
some people don't
and um like bernie's a character trump
is a character
there's one person that was nothing i
think it was like tom stein yeah
yay
his hair looks better short but that
thing where it looks like a comb over it
just doesn't not
you're never gonna be president of my
country um so with coaches you think
follow me on twitter and i and i'm
telling you right now
edit this out um so you think for
uh and i don't think it's a look i think
no no but a
character yeah you have to have a level
of
of you have to be verbose you have to
mo a leader of men they used to call it
i but they probably still
do whereas there are guys
that are black that have it and and
there are guys that are black that don't
and there are guys that are white that
have it and there are guys
that that don't have it and those are
the guys who become announcers yeah
i have a joke with blake and kevin love
like hey if you guys can't get
announcing jobs
after your career what about allen
iverson allen iverson's not gonna he's
not a head coach
no you don't think he could be no he is
verbose he's he's actually not the
verbose he's quiet
he's like a reluctant speaker he was so
like
fiery it wasn't language it was swag
that's why delicious i mean i want to
talk about swag gun to your head you
gotta [ __ ] derek rose around
al and i was in it all day i grew up
like ellen iverson's like
all my magazines allen iverson is by the
way chris rock did an interview with
allen iverson
that is outstanding to the point where
they made a documentary
around the interview how was he when
you're watching
basketball in live is he just was he
like [ __ ] steph curry or yeah he was
like steph curry but he was a better
he would go to the basket a lot so it
was like he would fight he was he'd
scrappy he was fighters
everyone liked him though the players
like him
but he was controversial i don't
understand he didn't like
practice and he he's not
he's from what i understand not the most
punctual guy
okay that's what i'm saying like as a
coach you have to be
like part organ your brain has to be you
just have to have an organized mind and
again don't make this racial because i'm
telling you
lebron has it steph has it uh
uh tim duncan has it now that's when i
went to china that we saw the
documentary
did you go see the documentary uh no
it's steph marber
um uh so nowitzki
couldn't coach he's just not
kobe could have coached in a second um
dirk dirk no couldn't do it great player
but just couldn't do it
german okay so so it's just like you
need to have this extra
you have to get you the coat the
manager owner yeah you have to be a
[ __ ] like
you know uh come on guys a [ __ ] part
dork yeah and like folders and all that
[ __ ]
like now having said that i've heard of
white coaches
who don't
they just sit outside practice smoke
cigars what
yeah oh there's [ __ ] about nba coaches
that you hear about i mean
a player that's not blake told me
about a coach who at the last second
timeout thing it's their ball and they
had
and the coach goes i'm gonna be honest
with you guys i'm scared
like just nba coaches that you're like
there's no [ __ ] way that happened and
that happened
uh are they still coaching yes
um they're a good coach they're good
you're just gonna be like
they just if you've been doing it it's
one of those it could be like a 10-year
thing where you're just not as
hot as you used to be you're not as hot
for this used to be not as organized
kind of a controversial question yeah do
you think there's
do you think one two-parter one do you
think they all bet on on their games
that they're in
players or coaches no players and
coaches no no
do you think there's uh i do worry
now that gambling has gotten more
exciting like it's part of it's part of
espn now
my worry you mean like fantasy no now
well now they do betting lines they do
vegas
betting lines on espn it's
all hand and glove now the thing i worry
about
is i would bet that there will be
a scandal of some kind come out
these guys all are friends um so
if it's like if i'm
if there was betting on comedy right and
i know
burr or mullany or dave or chris has a
sore throat
right the audience doesn't know it and
while i wouldn't bet on it i can't keep
will from
i can't wink at will and go i wouldn't
put a lot of money on chris tonight
right or just know that like yeah oh
he's doing this new material that is
yeah i'm like he told me on the phone
it's not good
that's friends cousins
moms yeah girlfriend that's
to me where the problems are going to be
well there's no sec
sec in [ __ ] there's no you can't
spell sec without nba
what's up there's knowing no last time i
checked scc don't have no nba um
do you think that things are rigged that
people would throw games and
any of that is there i don't know that's
i
believe my my from the outset and my
worry is
um you know his ankle's [ __ ] yeah
you know his angles i mean like whatever
that like
again i don't think uh
and i don't think giannis uh think of
poopoo
is
yeah i don't think he's gonna bet right
but if the 10th guy on the 10th guy on
the bench
yeah i think his cousin's going to bet
based on information
that his player cousin gives him and i
think that's
very hard to fight and fight it's very
hard to prove
a especially with the light phone um if
you get an untraceable light phone
uh but also it's
very human yeah you look at it with the
i think trump voters all thought
republicans are less corrupt they won't
do and then you look at the [ __ ]
it's just all all corrupt
it's all like soak her up where you're
like that guy's a millionaire why would
he
need to right make because they can't
because they
love money they love money
yeah so yeah so that's my worry would be
more like
interesting yeah would be that's where i
think
and maybe they have a plan for it i
don't know yeah like maybe they have
maybe they've explained to the guys like
if you're caught doing this
you're out of the league like not
one strike zero strikes yeah
one it would be one strike zero strikes
would be two that would be
everyone's out of the league's case
right now because i don't trust you guys
um so yeah i'm sure that they're like
there was a thing a guy got
had a had someone in his room at the
bubble
she didn't interact with anybody else
she did the apparently she was like a
mediocre
she was like a iffy five that was doing
checking them and like doing the covid
like running it i'd like the record to
show that i didn't put a number on this
woman
i said i would never do that well my
sister was like she was
not cute again but he was like man she
was
nominally in a quarantine she was in the
bubble because she was helping
she was doing she was doing covetousness
so he
did is he out yeah they they bounced him
and the players union was like can we
and they were like no
we can't we're not negotiating on this
because it's just
it's in the bubble what do you mean why
was it what's the problem
two adults [ __ ] in the bubble uh
because
first of all you do not know if she
[ __ ] up no i'm sorry um because it's
precedent yeah it's like then everyone's
just getting [ __ ] all over the staff
we can't have a we can't negotiate like
it's a hard and fast rule you can't
[ __ ]
really told clearly i thought you were
gonna say i hope you [ __ ] her good
oh no i was not gonna say that
i always think about quality of [ __ ]
um but yeah so he got bounced and then
his team got
his team lost so it's fine um i had a
movie idea that you're not going to like
ready okay i'm imagining i don't have a
title okay
just go 2017
okay a a newscaster
what does she look like isn't it
beautiful not a five an
eight you eight and eight
first thing in the morning eight okay
nine with makeup okay
um she gets into a horrible accident
that disfigures her face oh
and she can never be uh news she can
never cast
news again right okay
covet comes around everyone's wearing
masks
so it happened in a part of her it
happened basically
the whole bottom of her face is [ __ ]
up chemical you know i don't want to
look at it
right covered coconut yuck everyone's
wearing masks uh-huh
guess who's making a comeback eyewise
maybe
she's wearing a mask she's making a
comeback right have you seen a mask
yeah but like come back here what is she
doing she's doing
live news the problem with bianca's
taste in movies is
your comprehension's no good no she's
wearing a mask
she's wearing a mask relax i'm asking
questions
i will not relax you need to important i
need to just ask questions
the problem is you have a sensitivity
when i'm asking something you think it
as
an attack yeah just trying to understand
most
conversations aren't attacking okay so
she is makes a comeback in life
she goes back she gets to go back and be
a newscaster again
because she's wearing a mask because
you've asked two bad followers no no
just roll with it okay so she's doing
she's doing nude
newscasting she gets she does a job
interview they say take your mask off
she goes i'd rather not because of kovid
and they're like all right will hire you
on a temporary basis and she's a [ __ ]
newscaster she's wearing a mask
the whole time it's people fall in love
with her
the mask news what is how come
what kind of in terms of narrative yeah
okay
so it's literally like a kitty coaster
and then
covet and then yay like what the [ __ ] is
there where's the
what's the difference between this and
cyrano
the like old school yeah like roxanne
whatever you want to call it
um well i don't know i don't remember
that well of course you don't
yeah guy meets a girl he wants to
uh he's no love in this
america falls in love with her and
there's of course there's a love
interest to watch who
saw her this is like a this is like a
bad version of baby boom
no you gotta this is not a this it
doesn't go
i'm not i'm not actually gonna write
this that's i know we're just talking
about it um
um this is again you never apologize for
granny's house
and many of your friends said they
wanted to watch granny
you said you told me many i never said
man he was one
so this is this is an underdog story
it's a woman who
literally was banished from news
and because of her face it's
what's that woman who was on the who the
ugly lady who was a singer
like 10 years ago she was on one of the
contests british woman
oh yeah yeah
um what did you google susan boyle yes
it's susan boyle
this woman does the news and america
falls back in love with her because
she's wearing a mask
and at a certain end she gets to do this
thing she loved
finds love was like look it's kazakovic
otherwise i'd take my mask off
never takes her mask off and eventually
in the third act
um something happens where a bird comes
takes her mask off on the air
and uh and uh
it's la and then america's like you know
what i don't mind
she must have gotten some kind of
glycolic peel because i don't mind this
they would scarring of course they would
mind but it's a movie
um and uh and the guy falls in love he's
like i know you as a person
so i'm gonna follow it it's basically
sereno for the news with a mask
see at the theaters guys and by theaters
i mean
video on demand because theaters are
never coming back that's some good
narrative
i love it oh i had to use this
[Music]
observation
pretty much you know when people go i
got a death threat
so-and-so threatened to kill me yeah
ever pretty much everything's a death
threat
an open window is a death threat you
could potentially
fall out of it a set of steps is a death
threat
being awake you're under constant threat
of death
so it's all a death threat so we
remember we talked about this before
because every we were talking about
something
and you were like well she got a death
threat i'm like death threat is that you
have a great one the death threat is the
dick pic
of the modern first celebrities it's the
dick pic
it's the twitter it's the dick pic
social media dick pic yes it's a death
threat
no who's really like doxing you and
coming to your house
i mean everyone's so lazy everyone is so
lazy
they could find us what they really want
i don't know why
i'm looking for a co-host who likes my
ideas
um uh the
yeah it's all you're right about that
but it
some are credible you think but credible
death threats fine if i text you like
i'm gonna come to your house and kill
you neil
that's incredible like that what do you
mean credible i know
i will not say who someone who uh
did it has a tv show talked about saudi
arabia
having to get some powder in the mail
wow
and he's with his wife oh i know you're
talking about it yeah
that's so [ __ ] scary so
i don't know so is it
it just takes one person that's the
thing it just takes
one even kennedy said you can't stop a
lone
person he said it on in the car
in dallas well um no i'm kidding um
no one's that great um lux guy was great
but he wasn't a prophet no but if you
think about
all these assassins that kill let's say
celebrities
they're weird loners strange yes
it's just that one even someone breaking
into your house
like eminem and letterman they've been
like people over the years i think katy
perry had a stalker
um it's just taylor swift it just
becomes
it has an effect on your nervous system
but
sleep tight celebrities because
everything is a death threat
doc watch very quickly
[Music]
somebody a woman told me about a show on
netflix called formula one
which is a docu-series about formula one
racing which is not
uh i don't really like any car racing
this it's the best one uh it's very
how you say european very continental
and i think you would think all the
drivers are hot
lewis hamilton he's good looking a
little cheesy yes
i agree he's from like the shamar more
school of like handsome black men right
um
but there's a little there's um
there's a guy in and look up the driver
for renault
the renault driver f1 renault
that might be it daniel ricardo is there
a hot one yeah he's hot he's right pure
alley
oh go to that more face one okay
he's keep you know he looks a little i
don't love guys that
have this kind of mousey thing they
remind me of
there's a survival little fightful
um there's a do you ever watch uh thomas
the train when like
uh what's his face not as much as i
should done
but uh there was a part of it where
they'd go on the piano and there's these
puppets that live in the piano and
they they people with kind of prominent
noses like
just how he looks i don't know big eyes
prominence mousey yeah they look like
these puppets and i'm smiling he's cute
yeah i'm smiling there's a smiling one
just and a little more feminine i think
he's like it's
i like them to be manly i like my guys
smoldering like they're knocking
furniture over like i need a deep voice
in it yeah a little bit of a temper came
to the right place
say no more i'm right there formula one
is my point it's very good right and i'm
never gonna find it one of formula one
i'm on episode four
it's killer it's [ __ ] great for
a woman recommended it and i would say
it's it's because you don't think a
woman's gonna recommend a
driving show first of all because they
can they're not gonna
good drivers um
uh it's like a 24 7 but
less it's driving the reason there are
car movies that work
as i've explained is
drive there and if you don't speak
english
you know what that means and so formula
one they all do speak english but
it's just very literal like he is in
front of him he's trying to get past me
he cuts him off he's so funny there's no
charm to it they're well the cars are
[ __ ]
great-looking announcing no the actually
the announcers are fantastic
i'm just saying if you don't speak
english you can understand like
that red car right is in front of your
yellow car
but the drivers are eights and
uh neil annelid but maybe i like an
international man more than do you like
nascar
no no like what's why is it so trashy
seeming
cause relative to formula one it is
trashy cars oh the cars the cars are
trashier than the formula the formula
ones look like art
like those are the ones those are like
the sculpted you know
like they're legend i don't even give a
[ __ ] about cars right but they're
beautiful
yeah like they're oh definitely those
are really good looking yeah
like the first the formula one they go
200 and something
so and they have really good did you
watch the senna documentary
i think i did wait it's he was a formula
one guy he's he was a formula one guy i
started
yeah uh well this might not be for you
though uh but they're great looking
where's where's nascar once are [ __ ]
ricky bobby right
and they're all southern dudes so
there's all these guys are like
international they could be trashy
european i'll never know because i don't
know
a good european from a bad one whereas
americans i can tell you
i will score them based on their class
but never their race because it's not
not now no no
no now it's not the year neal lennox
hill did you check
lenox hill out it is a hospital
documentary show and i love a hospital
documentary show
oh really yes bring that up i love
a hospital documentary show it's great
do you ever watch er
trauma live in the er it's no it's not
like
there's no voice over there's no like
we caught up with michael who's getting
a foot removed it's just like
it's just like uh you know it's
that doesn't tell you anything but but
it's it's uh
it's just a oh there once there used to
be one called johns hopkins
that was about johns hopkins that that
ben carson used to be on which i liked
ben i think i
seen it it was 15 years ago probably but
i but that's how deep i've been in these
shows
uh it's a great show watch it class
action park
did you watch class action park no i was
with my family friends
yeah in your defense class action park
hbo documentary about
a water park in new jersey
oh the museum looked
so fun so fun like
i laughed watching half of the rides
they're so dangerous and they're run by
high school kids
i read an article yeah on this in like a
vice like a few months back
and they just it's just people detailing
of their experience going to the park
broken bones broken bones and people
literally died
there was a boat thing a guy got stuck i
mean
boat ramming there was like a there was
a
i mean it peop it's just ins look they
had a loop they had a [ __ ]
360 loop which they
sent down like dummies down
i mean it's so [ __ ] great just great
it honestly
when i read that article it made me
jealous yes
because i don't think i would have died
i think i would have had a great time
and then i'd be able to be like we used
to go there all the time you know i used
to go there
uh i love a water park and i don't you
like water parks
isn't that a [ __ ] plot twist of the
century you
i love water parks bianca you know we
gotta do
go to a water park i'm guessing wait i'm
guessing you're gonna say go to a water
bar
yeah but i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
we gotta go to that [ __ ] water park
in wuhan
where they had the concert night time
just give it a second
okay actually i mean now it looks fun
nighttime inner tubes concert wave pool
here's the thing though next time i go
to a water park
it's going to be after hours and it's
i'm going to
rent it i'm going to just rent it out
for me now
and it will if you want to come although
i'm not dying to see it
blank of course black will come only
course blake will come nothing would be
can chris rock he'd be happy to injure
himself would chris rock go just watch
grown-ups too they did a water park
scene oh they did yeah
is so no if you want to see chris in a
water park
i kind of my guess is he's not gonna be
there
blake has a better chance of coming you
and chris are the type of guys where you
want to see them
doing jovial things because you don't
seem to it doesn't seem there you go
there's chris evans oh he's having a
great time
they must have had so much fun filming
that look at how much fun spate was
having
he's pointing snyder's biting his nails
kevin james
having a great time they must have had
fun filming that no
they did i think it was in like they
shot
kind of in like massachusetts or
something so it wasn't
i think it was you know okay
oh i think it's okay okay i mean you
don't want to have to see
yeah you don't want to have to see your
friends you don't want to go to
it's like why people we want to use
dave's shows because i don't want to
[ __ ] fly to ohio to do 10 minutes
right it's a bit like that like go
somewhere for
for two months yeah um wait i really
will you actually rent out a water park
at some point
maybe are there any around here well
there's raging waters
where's that that's uh like near fontana
that's an hour away that's an hour okay
east okay
um there's 53.
straight down rain water we've got rain
and water look how fun raging butterfly
water park in la is raging waters los
angeles 2021
they are closed they are having a
private
session until next summer so but there's
some of these golf there's a com there's
some
combo golf land mini golf uh
water slide situations if you're telling
if you're telling if you're
asking me do i like mini golf i sure do
you ah you like mini golf
i used to i was on the i caddy growing
up wow but mini golf is different
not it's the end of it's golf it's the
end
it's putting pudding um okay
yusef hawkins storm over brooklyn is
about it's on hbo
about a guy who was
uh murdered by a group of italians
did you watch it no but i i've heard of
it yeah it's like it was a really famous
story in new york yeah
late 80s uh but it's it's good
it's just it's just a [ __ ]
it's crazy how openly racist
italians in new york used to be italians
oh i think all of them are
new york is the east coast is very
openly racist
yeah in new york it's a little more
philly i feel like philly's
white philly and philip philippines
are scary i don't disagree
sweetie but the funny part is that they
will hit on a black girl and a hot
or a latin girl in a [ __ ] millisecond
yeah but because you're not
i mean it's you're on break what
it's the same reason they boo they boo
football players when they're running
around
um just don't stop running around the
mistake football players make is
they didn't they weren't footballing for
a second um
football doesn't do football at the
wrong time um
that's very good love fraud on showtime
little iffy so far it's one episode
i don't trust the filmmaking what's it
about
it's about a guy who just married like
20 women and
milked them isn't it oh i wanted to see
that
you know what's funny though isn't it
funny when you watch a documentary
and you're just like i don't i don't
think yeah i don't trust the storyteller
yes
the editor i don't know what it is
there's something it's scotty it's like
how do you get that shot yeah and it's
[ __ ] like that where you're like
why is this a re like why is this a
reenactment yeah is this happening in
real time or you guys just happen to be
shooting yeah or is this it's a
problematic
have you watched the vow i listen i
finished the first
it's not it's like hard to get into yeah
it's a little did you notice that it's
like
yes because it's confusing
in that there's the cult and then
there's other
there's other people parts of the and
then there's like a cultie occult
and then there's like you're coming to
mike yeah and then there's slave
there's a slave master thing i will say
i've enjoyed it and
the thing i did like that i'm going to
start instituting is
if you if you tell someone a secret
you make them give you collateral so
that they can't
repeat it the problem with that is
someone's have to
someone has to really want to know your
secret right that's the point you can't
be like hey you want to know something
tell me something first okay i'm gonna
go i'm gonna you wanna know what i have
for dinner
send nudes and i'll [ __ ] tell you
otherwise you don't get to know what i
had for dinner and through this you know
what i have for dinner every night was
this
impossible burger yeah chopped up
veggies whatever bag
thing i watched a movie that wasn't a
documentary that's really good
you [ __ ] i know i'm sorry cheated it's
called a brighter summer day
brighter summer day a brighter summer
day have you ever watched yee
it's a chinese director edward yang yiyi
so [ __ ] good well you don't watch
movies anymore
uh but a brighter summer day is another
movie he did it's very good
it's four hours long
so i did it in parts but it's it's just
really
it's just good like chinese cinema
ask me if i'm going to watch yu ye no
you're not
oh sorry i'm sorry
are you watching yang stupid
let's do some emails l-s-t-m-e
l-s-t-n-e
you've got mail
[Music]
yeah what do we have let's listen some
songs
oh yeah this is funny oh and neil
is a wigger black man here
[Music]
no black man here can you play that one
again sorry
oh and neil is a
wigger black man here
beautiful so funny and another song
i believe it's called neil is it
[Music]
stanford
it's called they did a study pretty
great i wonder if you could tell i'm
hard right now
[Music]
i can't feel a bump coming through
i can't feel
[Music]
please delete that one no i don't ever
want to hear that again
cut it out well no you can leave it you
can leave yeah
um great well the middle they did a
study was by our friend right yeah
eric the great eric johnson one of the
greatest banking we'll use him
he actually sent a singles
uh dropbox which we could release
all the all of his singles he has seven
singles wow
ep dude yeah he's getting so it's pretty
great um
play the millennials audio question
please hey neil and binks lst and er
i'm wondering both your takes on
millennials in general a few weeks ago
you talked about millennial privilege
and got me thinking about it
general consensus is that millennials
are born between 1981
and 1996 meaning while bianca may be an
old caribbean woman on the inside
she's a dirty millennial on the outside
i'm noticing more and more people are
lazily referring to young people as
millennials
when they're in fact gen z's in 2019
your best friend ellen brought on a 17
year old to work
old things like a rotary phone and a
phone book when the girls struggle and
failed ellen said quote
that was better than i could have ever
hoped for well because you're a
millennial win or lose you're going to
get a prize
i'm born in 1994 the border between
millennials and gen z's
and millennials my age dealt with phone
books landlines and our grandparents
rotary phones
i understand my generation has its
faults but i think millennials are
getting
like [ __ ] on a little more than they
deserve we're not the ones partying on
spring break we're the ones cooped up
inside figuring out ways to pay off
student debt our parents didn't have to
deal with
and the participation trophy line is
[ __ ] we didn't invent those
boomers and old gen x has force-fed
those to their children because they
were too lazy to teach their kids the
value of failure
well that's the gist of my rant i just
want to know what the soyboy senses and
what dems determine
when it comes to millennials
[ __ ]
uh you're right about
the i think the participation trophy
thing
has more to do with not teaching their
kids failure just
they didn't want to have kids that were
failures in any way
i if you're getting into psychology
right also if
the i don't think i ever made this point
on stage but or on here but
if you're gen z or millennial and
someone says uh participation trophies
go
you should say yeah i'm gonna get our
participation trophy
for most shootings at a school
like the shit's gotten way worse in a
lot of ways
and economic inequality and pandemics
and debt and all the [ __ ] that that uh
you guys should use more in arguments
yeah honestly it had nothing to do with
that had are in no way your fault that
there's a you
born into a society where they're they
accept school shootings
yeah and they run rampant in your
lifetime uh
so yeah i don't i'm i'm
my problem with gen z is just the
entitlement thing and the
like everything's gonna be fair it's
like no no
everything's not gonna be fair i know
work stuff especially it's like no
you're not here for fairness also a lot
of
maybe this is not a real thing this
might be some pseudoscience but
a lot of gen z kids say
the nice thing is i feel like they don't
see as much of a difference in race like
they're way more
accepting that but a lot of them say
[ __ ]
interesting a lot where it's confusing i
mean again that's empirical it's not
like
they they did they didn't do a study no
that i'm just saying like
pseudoscience-wise yeah it seems
um just kind of like dude
it just seems well i mean that's how i
used it honestly
honestly like as much the n-word like as
a term of like what's up no but i'm
saying
when i did use it in the past it was
always like
dudes were n-words and girls were
[ __ ] no
no no no i mean how people say dude
what's up or like dude what are you
doing oh right i mean
yeah i don't know frequency it's
impossible to know like
if that's a rampant thing or just on
like the two skating videos you saw you
know what i mean
right it's honestly when i have gone to
the beach when i watch videos
younger cousins of mine who aren't black
who are persian
i'm like is this am i maybe i'm more
sensitive to it
and it's not that big of a deal or
what's going on
and i don't know i don't know i just
wonder about gen z
because that's one of those things
they'll they'll figure that out i'll
sort it
that'll help them don't take care of
itself okay
let's not get too deep in the woods on
that one all right
um they they'll figure out the n-word
stuff
um that's all we had for that right
yeah all right yeah we're not good yeah
so
gen z stop being so uh
thinking that work that there's gonna be
any justice at work
and in the world too and stop scolding
people but you know whatever
um goodbye if you do skull people make
sure you call them the n-word
you've got mail um this is a great
letter
and it deserves all the attention we can
give it rst and le
well that's nice please record
additional ad reads if i have to hear
that identical anchor pitch one more
goddamn time i
may literally die cheers mocks
he's right and i've been meaning to we
should we're gonna record two new ones
after today
we're gonna make them fun
and spotify goodbye hi
neil and bianca lcner well that's nice
oh this is a start up them friars we got
a long ass letter on our hands
okay um startup and bro here's the
situation one of my best friends and his
girlfriend
who i also consider a friend had a small
gathering of like six folks at their
apartment
uh he goes into covid which is not
related
the girlfriend had two of her friends
over during it one of her friends called
her girl a
whom i met for the first time that night
wanted to jump my bones
so bad that after i left i got a call
from my friend
telling me to come back because she
wanted to [ __ ] me
i was already 20 minutes away i had a
drunk pastor in the car whom i promised
to destiny to drive home
so i told my friend on the phone to just
give girl a my number
the very next day girl a and i went on a
date and we
had sex it was great
um she was a cool person and i was
excited for a second date
now two days later went and grabbed
drinks with some other friends
one of which was a girl call her girl b
whom i thought was into me
when i had first met her almost a year
prior i never shot my shot with her due
to general awkwardness and eventually
the flirting stop so i figured
i missed my chance we stayed friends in
a group context
rarely texting one-on-one and only
talking via group chat or
when meeting up with a group never
really thought anything of flirting
anyway after drinks was french she
privately revealed to me that she always
uh was crazy about me and that led to us
sleeping together
that night i did not at all expect for
her to tell me this and i didn't go
to grab drinks with the hope of it
happening i felt very conflicted but
ultimately
i had only known girl a for four days
and i already had a great relationship
with girl b
i didn't want to hurt anybody but the
truth uh
was someone was going to get hurt here's
where i think
my biggest sin came i cancelled my date
with girl a
which because of the timing of it all
was the day of our second date
i gave a [ __ ] not feeling good
excuse then a day after that
i gave her a wishy-washy i'm looking for
something else kind of text
my thinking was telling her that there's
another girl would hurt her feelings
more
upon further reflection that was uh all
just cowardice and i should have been
straight up as soon as possible
felt terrible a lot of emotions boy this
[ __ ] guy goes on and on
anyway here's the question am i an
absolute piece of [ __ ] for deciding to
go with another girl like that
or my right to think my only real sin
was lying if i sleep with someone do i
owe them the chance at a relationship no
matter
what happens in the next few days and
given the answer to that
how should i proceed i feel like i
properly explain and apologize for my
friend's girlfriend all i can do i take
it on the chin and let her be mad at me
or do i be more defensive my actions
interact because this is my character
uh how now fall and what book
great it was
it was a lot um and i cut some pages out
so
what you're welcome ladies and gentlemen
well he needs our health this guy
is a cruising for a person um
i'm more interested in your point of
view because i think my point of view is
probably pretty obvious
but i think yours might surprise some
people let's talk okay
uh no i think if it's the beginning
do whatever the [ __ ] you feel like do
what feels good go
down the path that feels good don't do
the noble thing or something yeah
oh girl a anything it it she wanted to
[ __ ] you
yeah if you want i don't [ __ ] people
that quick because
for just for situations like this and if
i think
i can have like fine sex and not be like
so what are we
very easily but i i think the if you
want to
position yourself to not go bonkers
don't [ __ ] a bunch of people immediately
me yeah not not everybody
it just doesn't i just want to know you
a little bit more and then i can
you know go from there so i don't [ __ ]
people that quick
for this reason feeling rejected and no
one's trying to reject you it's just
real life
so yeah sometimes it's timing it's not
about you
or like her [ __ ] stank it's just timing
and i i skim that the girl got like the
friend
here's the deal real life it's just life
don't
at the beginning people are just trying
to protect themselves and do it feels
good so i don't i don't think he owes
anybody
i i also think you do have to take it on
the chin like that girl's just gonna be
mad at you
and yeah it's gonna be awkward and like
but i
i this might be an la
new york small market thing like they i
this doesn't sound like he's in l.a or
new york because i feel like
people in l.a wow that was like one guy
yeah no i know like
it it whenever i see
a good-looking woman on the road at like
a gas station with a guy i want to like
grill the guy like
how'd you do that right and so i think
she expected
i'm gonna have to do this guy and then
we'll see what happens like going
forward
it wasn't like yeah i don't know in la
this girl just wanted to [ __ ] you and go
away
like yeah it's it's like a yes it's not
even a
it's she'd be crazy
to be like now like i wonder what are we
that's actually what i thought i'm like
what kind of weirdo is yes but you're
right that's good context
yeah uh so it is more
valued uh vagina is more valued in small
markets valued vagina
but i i don't think he's wrong i think
it's like what are you going to do
what are you going to do but i kind of
agree that you shouldn't you don't have
to tell her
that you that you get to say i don't
feel well or never owe
anybody anything yes it took me a long
time to realize that you can
sleep with a woman and she doesn't have
to be your girlfriend
yikes i know tell me about that it's a
lot of [ __ ]
energy wasted tell me you think
bianca it's my biggest fruit i think
that being respectful to women
is my biggest fear uh no i just didn't
no no what
woman is like it just seems
no it wasn't it wasn't even them really
it just it was
differently yeah i could have just like
i could have just
i could have been less i assumed she was
my girlfriend
it wasn't even her most the time so
the problem is if you sleep with them
more than a couple more than once or
twice then it's like well
okay this is a problem that's like are
we what am i yeah are we
to i don't know if we're exclusive i
don't really want to be but well goodbye
plus i always get them pregnant you've
got mail l-s-t-n-e-r
neil that's nice the champs remains my
favorite podcast of all time a few
times a year i still reminisce in lab
about felipe esparza's story
about smoking crack with a blind guy in
the wheelchair
um felipe esparza's episodes are pretty
great a little background about myself
i'm a white
male millennial living you piece of [ __ ]
you [ __ ] perform a [ __ ]
participation trophy
anyway when it's too hot or too cold and
i don't feel like walking to
or from the office i take the bus
because i'm a man of the people
also because taking ubers all the time
adds up for some reason there are often
numerous postal workers
riding this bus route at 5 pm i don't
know why here's why
they don't have cars they don't make
money
i mean i whether they mean on to get on
the job
no they have vans that they but they
don't own they don't drive the van home
you don't see like people getting
dropped off at school
in the so it's philadelphia people are
riding the bus
yeah um last summer well before coveted
i was riding said bus
home after work when a middle-aged white
woman said to a black postal worker on
the bus
thank you for your service at the time i
chalked it up as maybe this woman's
trying to publicly declare herself an
aspiring ally but in light of the recent
politicians politicization
politicization
not going to get there of the postal
service politicization
could she jesus could she have
been a time traveler from the future why
else would you publicly thank a postal
worker for their service on a credit bus
what do null fall and what do punk's
thunks
uh p.s bianca is ugly now you have my
email
okay uh i've been finding myself
very protective of postal workers and
fedex workers
in covid i'm like you good dog
yeah you need a you i don't know what to
offer them
but i'm like i cherish you you're going
after the
postal service who this [ __ ]
administration no but i'm saying
i'm just like why is that not a breaking
point for people
it's weird loses money i mean it's
because technically it's not a good
business but
if you see it the problem is seeing it
as a business
yeah it's not it's a service that we can
just function it's a service that
really helps does the military make us
tons of money
no we spend tons of money on oil
no but of course you know everything is
like a business
and we still spend the money to like
pay for all these [ __ ] family
so i'm like it's not that
oh it's just weird it's weird i don't
[ __ ] understand it
i i feel really bad that
just do like just a [ __ ]
out of it person can affect an entire
you talk about the trump i'm just i it's
weird that like now we're like protect
the postal service i never thought about
the postal service in my life
well that's we all learned a ton about
government
yeah during trump's time we're like what
a monument
i've never [ __ ] heard of a monument
uh it's funny when you
start learning about [ __ ] you thought
you should have known but as an adult
it's like [ __ ] i don't know what's going
on what's
going on we'll go ahead and google
emoluments
goodbye um you've got mail here we're
getting it we're
getting into fat city now hello neil a
long time
recreational user the podcast on face on
fat shaming
please just stop i'm a 34 year old woman
and i've been a plus size human since i
was four
which growing up in the 80s and 90s was
oh so much fun and in case you're asking
yourself plus size since 4
yes i started gaining excess weight at a
very early age
it's part genetic but is honestly mostly
now influenced by quote lifestyle
choices
or whatever condescending term is in
vogue suffice to say my weight has been
an issue my entire life
and it's greatly impacted my self-esteem
and relationships
it's something that i think about when
meeting new people
going out to dinner walking around
anywhere to the point
you've said some pretty shitty things in
the last three or four shows
don't you mean 30 or 40. from being
worried someone you date
which has had weight issues would yo-yo
and then become fat again
to repeatedly saying people that
criticize your parents are fats
i do look when you hear it back it
sounds bad but i stand by every [ __ ]
word i've ever said on here
why is your response to someone
criticizing your parents to turn around
and do the same
because they're in they're insulting me
from their frame
and i'm healthy they're not
you're not all of them are fat i promise
you they're all fat
i keep going also i am someone that has
treatment resistant depression and
anxiety a lot of my weight gain and loss
goes up and down depending on how well i
am functioning that month
someone that has been very open about
the depression can you honestly say that
your mental illness has never caused you
to lose or gain weight unexpectedly
or make you feel overall crap task about
your physical appearance
binky please jump in and hopefully
explain
to neil why he should stop with the fat
comments
this has been an internet rando
a jamie uh
you know let's just be real it's not
kind to call someone fat or say
disparaging comments about someone's way
you know this is my defense
how about driving out the old how about
drugs kindness
how about drug addiction where are you
going is it kind to say you're a drug
addict
uh what is it kind to say that someone's
drug addict i don't think it's
kind or not kind but why is fat
kind or not kind because i think
drug addiction is something that you
know someone's actually
battling go through it's a it's a
different category on its own whereas
some people are just
overweight and some people are fat i
think also we have to
you need to define what you call fat
because when you say
like fat people are probably suffering
from untreated mental illness like are
you talking about
rotund people are you talking about like
and to answer a question about
depression it hasn't
caused any weight or weight fluctuations
your metabolism
yeah that's what i'm saying it's like it
just hasn't uh
the thing that affects my weight is diet
and exercise
that's not true for everybody but it's
true for almost everybody
what to you is fat when you say fat or
he it's one of the
porn it's the supreme court point i know
it when i say it
okay so do you if you're if you're
don't go bmi chubby bmi is impossible
i can't tell on the eyeball test if
you're chubby i don't care
if you're chubby and you say i'm look
like i have aids
you're fat okay whatever i think that's
even stevens if people are
throwing yes fine and i don't i'm not
attracted to overweight people so if i'm
overweight that's chubby chubby
overweight whatever
so if i'm afraid someone's going to
yo-yo and be fat it goes to another
precept of
the houniful constitution which is you
got to honor the agreement and the
agreement was
i love you in this body or something
around this body
i i just think the problem is you seem
to talk about
overweight people more frequently than
skinny people you we talk about people's
weight like
she was fat i was attracted because she
was fat i'm gonna dm her even though i
don't
i honestly i don't respect people that
have a ton of debt
right i don't it's you've heard my rules
i don't it to me
overweight people cannot balance their
checkbook
and make very little effort to do so off
it's like you see with covet it's a
major health risk major [ __ ] health
risk
and part of the reason it took off in
america is because of the amount of
overweight people
it's not helpful it's funny i was with
uh i was talking to one of my friend's
mom and i'm a dick it's like that's why
i say drug addiction i was like dude
this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
really bad for your health and it makes
all
everyone's insurance premiums more
expensive and it's because
you're not responsible and i there's one
thing i ask you
is not responsibility
lack of responsibility i was talking to
my friend's mom who they're weird
i think they're trump supporters but i
don't [ __ ] want to get into it and
they were like they're fat i'm kidding
they're act they're not they're european
anyone i don't like when they're fat she
was telling me about the corona and i
was like oh you know i had it belong she
was like
what this country needs is to stop
talking about masks and start top
promoting vitamins and i was like
this is a really unhealthy country
it's been unhealthy for so long that
promoting vitamins
is going to go down just like uh
michelle obama's yeah
healthy lunch hey eat a [ __ ] carrot
you [ __ ] you terrorist [ __ ]
and it's true it's like dude this is a
symptom
of a giant problem so but okay i think
we can agree though
moving forward because we do we're very
careful with our
mental health feelers and i think maybe
moving forward we don't say
harsh fatty stuff maybe we say
maybe we say harsh fatty stuff i haven't
said
fat in a long time i i very rarely say
fat i said it earlier because i knew
these letters were coming
i think you said it i try not to bianca
bianca honey
you know my heart pure gold
the portugal
i don't it's a problem
yeah but there's a large portion of the
population you know what chevelle will
call me to make me insane sometimes
fat boy but then why does it make you
insane you're
clearly not fast no of course not why
would it make you insane
because he was skinnier than me why did
that why do you know how the table is
absolutely
why do you care oh why do you care
because it was disrespectful okay
because i was just kidding
something that i'm not i i i take
pride in the fact that i'm in good shape
it's not it's a pain in the ass i don't
like doing it
i do it because i want to be healthy
okay so
just for the record you're not a huge
fan of
overweight people no because i think
it's just irresponsible and it weight
it literally weighs down everybody is
that
if they're fun of course it's a pun you
see it
um isn't there something a bit
like you're really writing off a bunch
of people
because of how they're i get diet lack
of diet and exercise but also how their
body
if your amount of people
that who have a real uh
uh glandular issue is really
but
yeah uh i get that but don't you think
it's like kind of
writing off at large most people are
overweight in this country
if i again if i smoke cigarettes and
people go you smell like smoke i'm not
going to be like
oh what how dare
you know dear podcast
when you say peep smoker smell like
smoke
that's to me the same thing it's you do
a thing
there is a response i'm going to
so it's not that you don't like them it
just irritates you that they live an
unhealthy lifestyle yes
so say you like them of course i like
them you
i mentioned someone who used to call me
fat boy who's now
oh the tables have turned i'm still a
big fan
very big fan i like uh i like many many
of the fans
goodbye wow wow pineal
oh wait this is all right this is you've
got mayonnaise uh honey a long time
listener first time neil apology
demander
um uh neil's virtue signaling with the
adele photo in your most recent episode
really wrote me the wrong way and i felt
like i had to say something
again bianca pointed out we're the only
podcast that reads
our hate mail because it is mostly hate
mail it's funny
not because i'm a huge fan of adele i
think she's the
bud light seltzer to amy winehouse's
white claw
rest in peace and today's her birthday
but mainly because this virtue signal
has got to stop being a real thing
progress is going to be made
i love when people have these as if he
knows he knows this is
i've studied this why are liberals still
pretending like this kind of
appropriation is something to be
concerned about or that stopping it
provides any sort of
benefit to the quote victim of the
appropriation when jerry lee lewis
ripped off big may bell we had a problem
or when liz warren pretended to be a
harvard diversity hire
uh we had a problem but white
celebrities appropriating culture like
this never hurts the culture being
appropriated
okay tell that to justin timberlake
tell yourself [ __ ] tell that to
eminem
tell there's plenty of people this is
what this guy's promise is just
really uh he's kind of all over the
place yeah it's like
liberal i wasn't saying that
um that uh
i had a problem with adele i was just
saying like if we're talking about
the cancellation olympics she's
the cancellation game she's a red card
or it's a it's a
flagrant one it's not she wasn't kicked
out of the game he goes on to say
remember killer mike's saying that he
wanted more white clientelist
barbershops because they'll pay 60
for haircut if adele makes this kind of
hairstyle more popular among a white
audience
all she's doing is facilitating the
injection of money into the very
community she's
supposedly harming why are you trying to
harm these well again this guy's making
all kinds of associations what the [ __ ]
are you talking about so now i'm harving
black barbers
as if our black hair stylist as if white
people
couldn't do that first of all
she did bantu knots which are
i didn't love the bantu knots i didn't
love them i don't want
more white people getting bantu knots
and injecting money into first of all
they're not going to go
to their comparison yeah that's what
this guy fails to realize which we've
talked about repeatedly is it's
white people make money off of this [ __ ]
they make money off of
musical genres it's not eminem
actually dr dre made some money off it
but most of eminem's money
went to eminem and interscope
it jimmy ivy yes so
that's not black people benefiting also
i don't understand
when they rip off black culture
when they rip off black culture it
doesn't go
and it never trickles back down to black
people it goes
to fashion and uh in
in white people just stealing the
designs they don't go
why you still then you're trying to keep
this money out of what no it's never
going to black people
no what will happen here in the killer
mic example
is uh as you said
they will white girls will learn how to
do bantu knots
and uh the other thing about after
elizabeth warren there's no problem if
jerry lee lewis
bricks up uh big may bell
and but justin timberlake isn't ripping
off
black r b when justin timberlake when
jesse williams
said that whole thing and justin
timberlake just wrote inspired and then
he got
hammered yeah and i remember
someone that we know but not the person
we've been talking about
anyways a famous person was at the store
and he was saying how he was
chatting with justin timberlake about
and was like dude like
i felt so bad for him and blah blah even
justin was like
i get it yeah like he's saying i get it
in a [ __ ] mansion
yeah he's fine how about uh by this
guy's like
how about iggy azalea is she fine
because
you know t.i made some money there
let's not get rid of her because one
black person's making money it's not
about
one very rarely does a black person make
any money
and often times if a black person is
making some money a white person's
making
a lot of money also you weren't i just
really didn't feel like you were
virtuous
i wasn't purchasing a lot i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't i oh
my point was let the jamaicans
in england handle it
[Music]
you do i think everybody does no i went
to class
i think you've got mayo um neil i was
with you in defense of crystalline a lot
of smoke but not much fire that was up
until the last accusation if there's any
truth to them
damn it's all capped
hard hard to defend him anymore you may
feel different because you know him
personally but as
i as someone who enjoyed his comedy is
going to be hard
not to think of what he allegedly did
when trying to watch a stand-up
okay and so
watch mine wow um
i supposed to delay the other day and uh
and i'm not gonna say any more
other you know there's i wanted to get
it because people just
dip snippet but bless you watch
as i told deleo on the phone thanks for
letting me catch up a little bit
career-wise
it was thoughtful of him to allow
to have masturbated 10 years ago and
given his old buddy neil
that's right thank you and again if you
have
any information on ali wong or john
mulaney
please come forward and
goodbye help me you've got mail this is
about aoc
obama shared his netflix brackets and
stuff i'm sorry
ncaa his ncaa brackets and stuff
list of his favorite songs of the year
etc what if
makeup is just a hobby perhaps geared
more toward one gender like sports she's
essentially engaging in sharing her
thoughts on
something real quick if it's just an
interesting hobby she
knows a portion of her voters are
interested in and is one of the attempt
to be relatable things politicians share
for a lot of middle and lower class
women makeup
is a lot like sports i'm pretty sure
this guy's a guy so he's no [ __ ] idea
what he's talking about jacob is a lot
like sports yeah
again that's proof lower
class women you know how lower class
women are it's like sports for them
it's not about actual looking prettier
because they're lower class how could
they look prettier
to conform or sell magazine to look like
a model it's just a fun thing to learn
about talk about
only middle and lower class women lower
lower qua you know what i'm saying
different than doing snl a performance
of acting or comedy blah blah as a
journalist that's just dumb
i think this is slightly different i got
bad news for this guy
i [ __ ] hated obama's ncaa brackets
every time he did it i just thought go
be president go [ __ ] be present i
think the fact that anyone thinks his
his lists are cool is that it's like why
do i care what a 60 year old black guy
is listening to
music wise i just never understood like
he's not a [ __ ]
connoisseur he's a he's a former
professor
who doesn't have an especially good
taste and it's fine
but it's not like oh wow go on pitchfork
this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
hears everything
um that and then the news people
i don't know what he's getting into but
this guy he's just saying like
uh everybody does it right but i'm
saying
no one should do it he's saying it so
badly it's one of the worst letters
we've ever gotten
lower-class women makeup is a lot like
hey go
whoever you are go sit on your roof for
an hour you're on
you're on punishment goodbye um watch
dalia's special
on your roof a lot of the stuff
here you go here's another one oh here's
another apologize
you've got a lot of stuff you get wrong
requires a long explanation but you guys
don't read a long emails
[Music]
uh you discourage long emails which
makes sense a short amount
can't always lay out how twisted
something you said was but don't mistake
that for being correct
it's easy to say you don't have to agree
with us but when what you're saying
is it's disrespectful or dignified for a
33 year old
or it's respectful or dignified for a 33
year old
man to date a child or to dm a girl who
has photos of herself standing by
lockers
on high school grounds with her high
school named on social media an obvious
teenager
that's when that's not something people
are going to shrug off and say
well i don't agree it's shocking to hear
someone so casually excuse predatory
behavior
i don't think either of you understand
that it'd be one thing
if you were excusing behavior no one was
compliant
complain about that's she [ __ ] up
uh but when the young girls come forward
saying these men were harmful and you
still make excuses for it
still downplay it don't act like all the
hate mail is coming from irrational
people
who just tolerate any who just can't
tolerate any disagreement
this woman's been trying to comment um
ladies
three things happening here you want to
go first
okay one you're i like what is
what isn't she mad about uh-huh the long
emails
rich is saying they sometimes are too
long so ignore that
ignore um i just feel
like she's bad faith interpreting us
because i don't of course it's also
anything she
we never excused anything delea did
um and the thing where i said it's
respectable
or dignified if you can find
video of me saying that that
any sort of proof uh where i said it's
respectable or
dignified for a 33 year old to date a 15
year old
name your price literally name your
price
because i'll give it to you if and no
will you what you
you kind of she'll go you kind of
implied it no
no i didn't i said maybe i said maybe
there's something to be said
and then by the way we cut it out lady
so
we cut it out of the podcast for
different reasons
and so it's gone it's out of the public
record
so it can't where it can't nor i can't
normalize
that kind of behavior you know who who
you could also write this to
the cops or the d.a
if you're so mad at these people
then write to people who can do
something rather than someone
who's just bullshitting about it yeah
we're not but the fact that you wasted
your time
and are like i don't think you get okay
what if i don't get it then what
what if i don't get it what happens what
happens if neil brennan
a a comedian who lives in venice
california come and try to find me
doesn't understand the um
the uh impor the predatory behavior
of my friends this is not something i
engaged in
and i by the way i do understand it but
let's say i didn't
then what then what would happen what
are you worried about then i'm gonna be
on a jury
that i'm gonna publicly say i like it
what are you worried about
what's the walk me downstream
from here i mean also we're not
making excuses like she's
framing it i think
as a podcast culture we are against
cancel culture we don't like jumping the
gun and then we're also hypocrites
because
i'm also like dox these racist [ __ ]
you know so
gypsies we just no no
i i i love my gypsies you guys know my
heart
is my gypsy heart um no
so i just think she's she just i think
this lady's written before she's trying
to dm me
it's like lady what are you trying why
are you holding
what i say as
particularly meaningful i didn't write
to the new york times
and try to publicize this i i'm not a
member of nambla
this is the north american boy love
association disgusting
um i'm not i don't think it's cool
i don't think it's good i don't i've
never done it myself
i so what and also if i did believe it
then what then what
it's like people who it was illegal to
smoke weed
everyone was there were some people that
were fine with smoking weed and some
people who still thought
it should be illegal what i'm not one of
those people
but what do you do when something's
illegal and you think it's stupid
i'm not one of those people but again i
don't understand why she's
fixated on us it's like lady right take
the time you wrote
there's quotes there's uh
she parenthesized things three
paragraphs she really thought
right to a congressman yeah there's
hyphens out this [ __ ]
my thing is like dude on this podcast if
you listened
we tackle these sort of things
these me too tackle is even a big word
yeah sometimes we barely slapple we say
while we drink snapple um
we just don't like canceled culture all
while being [ __ ] but we do
our best to try to uh not join the mob
and relax and look at it rationally and
see okay what's that what do we got what
are we working with yeah why do you
do you want do you listen to podcasts
so that i condemn laws that have been
broken what do you why would you
listen to something that just like and
here's a layers of jaywalker that's
wrong
right and then here's did you see this
guy he's wrong who gives a [ __ ] we're
trying to
do something here which is maybe like a
different take at this thing that's part
of our culture which goes
into cancer culture but i don't even
think we're consciously trying to go no
not at all but when i look back i just
know we don't have
we're not sitting there with the motive
of i'm not we're not actively
let's have a discussion we're just
actively
not when we look back and i listen to
our take on things it's just to not
it's just to take our time and like
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
that's all
we are not bringing up hypotheticals i
don't know we are not the judges
again you're the irresponsible one
because
you're so passionate about this and yet
choose to write into podcasts
about it also there is there are two
to your mind two predatory predatory sex
criminals
on the streets right now and you're what
did you do
i wrote into a podcast that
made glancing comments that
was uh condemned
condemn both of them i mean the thing is
it i'm i think i'm happy to get scrappy
and talk with someone about or respond
to an actual specific email but this
just seems
well shaming and upset and she seems
upset
from a while ago so i don't know where
they're she wants she wants an apology
and and unfortunately
she uh she came to the wrong place not
always we'll apologize
we have a goodbye you've rsv you've read
several of my questions on the pod and
help me through a couple tough choices
so i figured i'd come to y'all with an
issue that's caused me a lot of distress
i'm 24 year old and currently in my last
year of law school i went to law school
with the sole intention of becoming a
public defender
my brother was arrested while i was in
college for robbing a bank jesus
in the midst of a serious addiction to
heroin and it's currently serving a
15-year sentence
dudes it's crohn's
i saw the ins and outs of the criminal
justice system and developed a passion
for the subject that i knew i had to
pursue
spent the first two years of law school
interning at the public defender's
office in my country
in my county and i absolutely loved
everything about it
uh long story short i was planning on
continuing to work there this past
summer but in the early stages of covid
i was offered and accepted a high-paying
clerkship with a law firm
that defends corporations uh like an
airline and an insurance company against
my
against personal injury lawsuits wow
uh yeah i went from trying to save into
indigent civilians from jail
to lower middle class women uh from jail
who love makeup for sport to trying to
keep huge companies from paying the
medical bills of innocent people that
were hurt dude
my issue is this do i stay with this
firm given the uncertainty the economic
future of the country
or do i go back to public interest
public interest
sector and do what i am passionate about
despite the drop in pain prestige okay
go dude you're just gonna have to
dance with the devil a little bit
everyone does it whether you're in
business entertainment people take awful
jobs that pay money
but just i directed a popeyes commercial
louisiana fast but i mean i'm not i just
i'm vegan
right it's no it's hilarious it's a
problem get in all the money
if people are gonna throw money at you
take it all in yeah
get to a point where you're good and
then
dedicate yourself i feel like a lot of
like i had there was like an interview
with
scott kahn is that his son is that yeah
he was saying that he does shitty work
so he can just do indie films and
passion projects that he wants yeah
it's like you gotta like take from
someone or you don't have to
i have friends that are social workers
yeah well that's the thing
well this is the story of morals
basically this is what happens this is
why i can't wait for
all the gen z millennials who have all
this fairness and it's like
everyone's for fairness until they have
kids and then they're like
[ __ ] i gotta feed these [ __ ] i
need to get
money to feed these [ __ ] but
it's almost like
are you i'm down with a robin hooding
my worry and as it usually happens is it
takes too long
to get enough money to do the right
thing mm-hmm it just takes too long
and you get stuck in there you get your
lifestyle lifestyle and you start
spending more
so what i would suggest is to
flip it where your
do the right thing for like five eight
years
and then and then start back in the
wrong thing so this is where
you're not taking consideration the fact
that people like
ageism is real and people like to hire
young people especially in those kind of
jobs
so they're not gonna want you
in 10 years as much as they'll want like
a young scrappier person that's just
it's just there's ages yeah that's why
most people like i work for a consulting
firm i think you just line your resume
just do a chemical field that costs 100
do a chemical paper
on your resume uh i know of a woman who
pretended to be black
and many ripped queen um yeah like when
i was in consulting
everybody did three to like seven years
of awful very lucrative
work that sucked and then everyone just
did like
now they can go do their own private
thing or they can go into a smaller
company that they like and they still
get that position they still get the
money because they're important
but not as much but so i don't know i
feel like you can find a strategy
here you're a she's a lawyer right
uh i think it's a guy um yeah he said
yeah i think
my worry i still stand by my thing
because you won't get hooked on the
lifestyle
whereas there's a very high chance
you'll get hooked on a lifestyle and
then you'll get married
you'll have kids and then you'll be like
well [ __ ] the [ __ ] the indigent
[ __ ] those middle and lower class women
who like makeup
sport did you see that one the camera
who's your favorite makeup team by the
way mine's l'oreal
um i like elf i like
elf i don't know about elf elf is good
um and then there's a bunch of like but
pat mcgrath it's like a black owned
it's she's she's uh biting from ir she's
appropriating irish names
okay um so wait you cut me out
yeah i don't i don't think uh i think
i still vote that you should do the do
the
do the public defender first okay that's
just me
goodbye um uh
let's do one more you've got mail oh
this is a good one
yeah read it dear it's so loud
um dear and neil and bianca the face
sitter
rstlne i've watched two neil shows in sf
nice thank you lol at bianca is
struggling to remember steven you want
to see
in episode 68 okay context i am a 29
year old black
male working in the yay area tech
race because why not dating a girl for a
few months she's 28 in white
she's in med school and absolutely
terrible at texting back two to three
days
and making time for me she swears she's
still interested in me but just
generally not good at the above question
how do i help her get better at
responding
time management but also not look too
needy really not looking to go back to
bumblehinge in the age of copen how neil
feel and what
the facesitter thinker p.s bianca please
go to the wedding it was this weekend i
can't go anymore okay guys i hope you
got coveted in oakland
um no no i tested negative uh this is
one of the rare cases where i would say
don't read anything into it yeah she's
in med school like meds
it's like dude they're [ __ ] you ever
watch if you watch
lennox hill you'll see the hours these
people put in but
i would oh go ahead just let it if you
like her just
or some people though
two to three days drives them crazy and
it hits their anxiety so i would say
maybe this isn't the right fit yes
either yes you're not going to change
her though
and don't don't try just tell her like
hey this kind of bothers me like
can have a honest to god conversation if
she's like i like you
this is when i have time it is what it
is then take it or leave it buddy
or you could do what men have been doing
for hundreds of years which is
shaming a woman out of her interests and
desires
and putting his before hers you could
try that
yeah i go for it
dress up shamer shoe shamer goodbye oh
this is you've got
mail the uh
this is another one which is like a girl
said she had to think about it
which is cut to the meat and potatoes of
it a girl he he
told a girl he liked her she goes let me
think about it which
that's not a good sign that's not if
unless she's in med school
it's not good yeah exactly uh if a girl
talks to you like that
the one question you have to ask is hey
are you in med school
and if she's not she don't want to see
your dick uh hey neil bianca jay here
again
as if we know even though bianca's
weight oh
jay um even though bianca is waiting and
taking your time watching it no
shade i'm watching the vox hbo
documentary about
the nexium cult and i'm genuinely be
followed most cold documentaries i chalk
up to some white people with low
self-esteem [ __ ]
um however this is the first cold
documentary i can actually understand
how people were misled
and indoctrinated by the cult of
personality still it begs the question
why the [ __ ] and how the [ __ ] can you be
so enthralled by a person's character
that you give thousands of dollars in
time and drive yourself to the point of
exhaustion and suffering just to please
someone you admire
and it seemed like the fact that they
were celebrities that uh
were part of it that influenced people
even more what do you guys thought since
you guys have been around more
uh i feel like if will smith started a
church he'd have more than
ten thousand parishioners in a day just
because he's will smith uh
you are correct sir and um
the while
attention is a
currency charisma
is the greatest commodity
a human being can possess yeah across
the board
it's they it's the definition of
charisma is you want to say yes before
you know what the question is
yeah and if you have charisma you can
write your own ticket
you can be tall i'd rather be if someone
said would you rather be six eight or
charismatic charismatic
because if you're charismatic you're a
million feet tall
um remember when you read that book and
on the chart yeah and you try and you
did it it was so funny
i do remember he went around and was
like
to be charismatic you have to remember
people remember people people's names
and then he made a chart with all these
people's names
that worked at the store yeah and he
didn't even know any of their names
because i
i only studied once and i if you're you
joke i thought about yesterday
during covet this is a good time to bone
bone up
on some some staff's name no this is
what you gotta do
you just gotta you just gotta say it
immediately oh da da and then say it
again
oh really i just i need to write [ __ ]
down you know what i do
i do uh uh that's why i give nicknames
yeah but then you're george w bush
here's a new one
based on effective communication
this is my screensaver but
my lock screen not words not actions
tone tone ladies and gentlemen wow it's
like neil had a lobotomy or something
it's off too oh wow [ __ ] you
you suck
this isn't worth it yeah no it is show
it just put it in later or send it in
the picture
it's uh it's it's everything
it's funny i was watching love on the
spectrum and
a lady comes with them and sits and is
like um no you have to ask her
how is she you know when you don't just
start talking and they're like taking
notes
and you're kind of like that when it
comes to certain random things like you
if it makes sense to you you're like oh
that's actually a good note to take
forward
with me to be more effective at
communicating or whatever
and then you actively do homework you
have to
i i have to i don't think anything this
is why i don't like bad people
no we the overweight the weight
the over of weight uh
um we already said yeah i'm kidding um
the yeah but it is i i'm going to get my
tone is better than it was a month ago
all right well as usual guys we
still don't have to take this [ __ ]
um we wish you a blessed week
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
um
you